the student here at Berkeley and has
worked several projects including sexy
which he'll now thanks for the intro and
I'm here to talk about sexy which is our
work on constructing a system for
decentralized private computation and
this is joint work with Shaughnessy cash
my adviser Alessandro Matt and Ian or
JHU and now I think at Cornell tech
stuff I'm not sure and Howard okay so
let's get started if you want to compute
on in a distributed ledger like you
won't have a smart contract system we
have a number of these I we have a
theory on tezo cos and more popping up
by the day right and how these eat I
mean there's like lots of differences
between them but the common thread
amongst all of them is that they all
work by re execution right well this
means is that whenever you propagate a
transaction to the network every node to
verify or validate that transaction has
to be execute the computation inside
that transaction right and if everybody
agrees that you know this computation
outputs 10 then the transaction is a
valid transaction and it's confirmed on
the ledger right this is the standard
model arrays of this sort of Rijeka
queuing model has a couple of issues in
terms of scalability and privacy from
the scalability perspective the issue is
that you know you have this piece of
computation but your network might
consist of nodes which have differing
computational power itu might have like
a server class machine but also a mobile
phone in the same network and if all of
them you know want to participate in
network properly they all have to
validate this transaction which means
they all have to execute this
computation right and this means that
now your weakest node is sort of the
bottleneck in the network right and this
is independent of any you know consensus
layer improvements you could think of
even if you had this ideal consensus
under contents mechanism underneath you
would still have to you know validate
each transaction and so you would still
face this weakest node bottleneck right
okay so that's one skated the deep
respective
in the privacy of perspective right when
you send out this transaction to the
network anyone can see first of all
which program is being executed right
which contract is being executed what
data is being is being provided as input
to the computation and finally who
invoked or who is like the caller of
this program right and this information
is permanently stored on the ledger for
all time and as methods of analysis get
better over the years this information
only becomes less and less private right
impression illness this make sense
hopefully okay so what we do in sexy is
construct a ledger based system that
allows users to you know conduct these
computations offline and then just
publish at the stations through the
correctness of these computations right
and here's XE stands for zero knowledge
execution we will see where these two
parts coming in a second right the
properties that we get ins XE are first
of all privacy the civil zero knowledge
part comes in the idea is that the
transaction reveals absolutely no
information about the offline
computation so what we saw in the
previous slide write information about
the executed program the input data the
color all that information is supposed
to be hidden in jacksie right so every
a transaction for every computation
looks the same they're all
indistinguishable so that's in privacy
in terms of efficiency of solving
solving the scalability issue what we
achieve in sexy is the property that
every transaction can be validated in
time that's independent of the size of
the computation and concretely for our
implemented system we have the
transactions are less than a kilobyte in
size no matter how larger computation is
and they all verify in less than 50
milliseconds
feels no infor about offline computation
I need to know what you computer no no
you don't ever get to get to see that
yeah that's really cool property like if
you're not part of the group which is of
the person who is involved in the
execution of the computation or do you
know is that this transaction whatever
computation occurred in that transaction
you know that it was correctly computed
but you won't learn any other
information about that computation now
we'll see how that how you achieve this
in a second yeah it's a pretty done to
to a contra intuitive sort of property
just take it unfit for a couple of
slides alright there's some scalability
as I was saying at the transaction as
the size of transaction the verification
time is independent of the concrete
computation that you're performing even
if you have you know this MapReduce
sighs cluster making a computation yeah
the transaction in the end will still
have these properties and finally you
know to achieve these properties we
don't sacrifice in terms of
functionality or expressivity what we
have is that we can support arbitrary
user-defined functions so whatever
computation you want you can express it
in this system we still in really late
malicious functions from honest one so
you know if you have some malicious
malicious attacker that's maybe putting
out like a bad computation you can't
that computation won't affect the
execution of honest computations and
also we don't completely isolate there's
still like some sort of managed
communication between these different
computations yes the functions getting
tracked yeah this is all like a nice
property but and also we don't need we
don't just have a you know theoretical
framework we also show in a paper how to
construct some example applications such
as private user-defined assets so
multiple tokens that are completely you
know offer zero cache style privacy also
you know private stable coins which have
different sort of properties around
issuance and transaction validation and
stuff and also exchanges decentralized
on custodial exchanges to trade these
assets
and we'll dive into a couple of these in
the top you feel free to interrupt any
point to ask any questions anyone
actually building any of those three
things
so I'm most people have reached out I
don't know like where it's gone I so you
know I we haven't implemented systems
I'll talk about at the end the code is
available online
I haven't yet published I mean I think
doing this would be the easiest to get
started off and it yet published code
for how to do that in everyone has
really interesting days or doesn't yeah
it would
yeah silicon is basically this sort of
assuming feel if you know about like
Bitcoin at the value of fluctuates you
know by thousands of dollars over a week
or so the point of a stable coin is that
its value is sort of pegged to some you
know other currencies in some sense like
real world or crypto currencies and the
idea that the value doesn't fluctuate as
widely or rapidly
there's like some collateral like
backing company which like and says I
have a dollar and we'll give you this
token because I have a dollar now you
can redeem it for a dollar in the future
and God as a value doesn't fluctuate too
much you know it's a basket of
currencies exactly I think libras also
in their values I think there's a pirate
corner but it's still encoding of
different problems it's stable oh yeah
yes the simple I want the state never
complain you over here well no no it's
just that every stable point that's been
released thus far as trend to it that's
been transferable on a completely public
blockchain like aetherium or something
like that
and this is partly why I think
regulators are somewhat comfortable with
the concept of stable coins I think
you'd be very interesting if there was a
stable point that travelled over more
private blockchain yeah the key the key
I guess basically there's some stable
coins are somewhat like more regulation
friendly right and I guess going from
here to here the additional part is like
adding this sort of regulation friendly
nature but still then telling some sort
of privacy stable is just regulated
because you are wondering about private
and regulator the introduction between
private yes how do you satisfy
regulations while still having yeah
maybe should chain that a regulation
friendly or something so in this talk I
won't talk about sexy but the full
general system instead we will see how
you can take these ideas that I talked
about to construct a couple of your
applications namely private user-defined
assets and
Dex's and maybe if you have time well
dive into you know these private
regulation friendly coins all right so
why digital assets right if you look at
smart contract systems today probably
the most successful and widespread
application of these systems is you know
issue custom user-defined tokens or
assets alright so if you're able to
support this use case the only
supporting like is X you can support the
choose case it's all the you know has a
useful application right there right
and also the ideas that you know if you
look at systems like aetherium yeah the
CRC 20 tokens your 721 tokens you have
these regulation friendly stable coins
and all these are like sort of different
issuance properties and transaction
properties and controlling authorities
so if you're able to support this sort
of wide variety of use cases then it
exercises the flexibility or
functionality that I talked about on the
previous slide ok so once you have these
like the natural question that comes up
is how do you actually go around trading
these types of people wanna trade assets
right so today there's two primary
methods of doing this right you have
these centralized exchanges I mean the
idea is that I as a user give up control
of the asset to there's some third party
called the exchange right and it manages
trades on by behalf because it has full
control over my funds right the problem
with this is that it can lead to and has
led to in many cases loss of funds due
to fraud on the part of the exchange
security breaches or just plain old
human error like millions probably maybe
billions right now of dollars of like
user funds have been lost because of
mismanagement at the exchange okay but
it's not all negative they do have some
nice properties first of all they are
more efficient in the sense that because
now every trade is just like you know
changing some entries in the database of
the exchange you don't have to go to the
blockchain for every trade for every
transaction right and this results in
infrequent auction activity which is a
plastic you don't wait like 10 oh like
10 minutes or an hour for your trade to
go through and they also have some
notion of privacy right because as I
said you're only abetting entries within
the database of the exchange right you
only the exchange really learns
information about the trade like who's
trading with whom because none of it
really hits the chain until like you
know it's in a masked accumulated
package
and none of that information really goes
to the blockchain off about individual
trades okay only the exchange you see
this information the US government sure
through the exchange yes okay so going
back to this point so to solve this
problem of you know custody of assets
and in some sense okay not yet but this
may need to solve is probably a problem
of giving up the custody of assets to
this third party people have come up
with decentralized or non-custodial
exchanges and the idea with this is that
users retain custody of their assets
throughout the trading process at no
point does you know the secret key for
particular account or whatever go to
third party exchange the user has full
control at every point in time okay and
in some sense they are responsible for
performing the trade but this brings its
downsides right for almost every non
Cristal Exchange that I'm aware of you
have to perform on chain transaction for
every trade that you make right so now
you incur the latency of the main
blockchain say you lose out in terms of
efficiency but also you know existing
block chains are all you know public key
theorem you can see what transactions
are occurring at any point in time right
so you lose this privacy something
somewhat privacy guarantee that you had
from centralized case because now the
observer can see any any observer can
look at the blockchain and see this
trade for as a day as it be at this
price occurred right so you don't have
any privacy yeah there you have the sort
of this aggregator right which comes in
and rolls up so you would yes you would
have privacy with respect to yes they're
like it's all aggregated and in some
sense only the aggregated transaction
goes to the ledger yeah
okay so then this stock I mean because
it there are solutions for this sort of
scalability issue right including startx
and plasma and such I'm going to focus
mostly on the privacy aspect this
privacy shortcoming right and concretely
so let's take a look at like what the
concrete leakage is right the first
problem is that as I said like every
trade goes on the ledger right and this
reveals information about who's
performing the trades I could send
receiver our what assets are involved
and what the exchange rate for these
assets was and what the amounts traded
one and this has like a 2x effect first
of all the you know negatively impacts
financial privacy of individual users
right because it goes all is all
publicly viewable on the ledger and this
first of all reduces fungibility because
you can see the history of every all the
funds in a trade men can also revealed
secrets about you know the proprietary
trading patterns of a particular user or
something which they might want to keep
secret right so it first it harms use a
financial privacy but maybe you're like
okay this is acceptable you're gaining
is he centralized you know we don't have
to lose custody process maybe it's okay
right but so it's not just you know
individual users this sort of lack of
privacy also impacts the global security
of the entire not only decks but also
the entire blockchain actually for
example one problem is with
front-running right so if you're a minor
in the theorem or something you can see
big orders as they go out and then you
know you have some information about how
prices are going to change so you can
place your own order before the
transaction is confirmed and now you can
benefit or profit off of you know this
difference in prices all right and this
is not just a theoretical attack there's
been a series of works and by folks at
ic3 over at Cornell Tech like the flash
boys 2.0 paper but the show like how you
could actually leverage the sort of
information to actually make profit in
the network when they have odd attacks
but this sort of public information
allows you to can even like destabilize
then security of the entire theorem
blockchain for example yeah some cool
attacks are yeah so the point is that
this is not just a theoretical attack it
actually happens or it's possible to
execute in
practice
so let's see how you would solve this
right so first we would construct these
private user-defined assets and then we
would see how to construct this private
decks to trade these assets so a
starting point will be the zero cash
protocol and we'll focus on this first
of all because you know it offers for a
single asset at the best possible
anonymity guarantees that you could hope
for and also it'll be like the building
block for our actual construction as you
can see so zero cash what happens is
that each transaction consumes some old
coins and produces new ones and the idea
is that the sender receiver and value
are all probably hidden or each
transaction looks indistinguishable from
any other okay in a little bit more
detail each transaction contains for the
old coins it produces the serial numbers
for the spent coins and contains for the
new coins commitments to serial numbers
for those new coins right so as you
append more transactions the idea is
that even if you know I spend that coin
produced in the first transaction in
this new transaction in this latest
transaction nobody will be able to link
that commitment to this serial number
the idea because that's because the
commitment is hiding along with the
guarantee that they'll be like as your
knowledge proof somewhere in here which
guarantees that you're not making money
out of thin air that value is conserved
across transactions
yeah and I'm an empty guarantee that you
get is basically that you know when you
spend a coin this add an empty set is a
set of all possible or all past coins
that were created right so when I have
SN 5 it could have come from any one of
the commitments in the past there's no
way to figure out which commitment it
came from which coin it came from
and questions about the immunity
guarantees here let's dive in in a bit
more detail so yeah this is the
transaction right as I said it has
serial numbers and commitments and what
it additionally contains is your
knowledge proof which proves some
information about these these two things
so first the proof talks about the you
know the old coins that are consumed in
the transaction and what it shows is
that these all kinds that I'm spending
exist they are actually produced in some
past transaction and this technically is
done we have some proof of membership in
a local tree but the point of this step
is that you know I'm not making money
out of thin air right so that's you know
I'm spending money that I created the
next point is I want to show that the
serial numbers of the coins that I am
spending you know these ulamas will
derive correctly from this old coin
right I'm not making up incorrect serial
numbers when this is done again
technically we have some sort of PRF
derivation using this information not
super relevant for the talk so okay so
know what what I know now is that the
coins that I'm spending were created in
the past and are not being double spent
because the serial number is derived
correctly and it's supposed to be unique
all right okay
and finally about the new coins you just
want to show that these commitments are
constructed correctly they actually
correspond to some you know public key
address or something and actual value I
finally want to prove that so that value
is actually conserved in the transaction
that the sum of the old values is equal
to some of the new values and maybe some
chain information for transaction fee
yeah these are the properties that you
want in private transaction right and
the idea is that the zero knowledge
proof enforces these properties but
courtesy of the zero knowledge property
it reveals no information about any of
the old coins or the new coins or
anything else all you see is that the
transaction has some serial numbers and
some commitments and as your knowledge
proof
okay
questions about this just it gets a
little more technical this is like the
key building blocks if you have any
questions in the ass enough that's
alright so zero cash as you saw it Eve's
this ideal anonymity guarantee for a
single asset on a single blockchain
it's been deployed as a cache already
right so the question that we want to
ask is how do you achieve this you know
this ideal privacy guarantee for
multiple user-defined assets on the same
block chain right that's what you want
to answer now straightforward or like
naive way to do this would be to you
know if you have asset a acid BS let's
see just independently run instances of
the zero cash protocol for acetic acid
BSC right so you have zero cash a for
trading in a zero cash P for trading in
B and their cash C for trading in C
right
can anybody tell me like what the
downsides of this approach are
yesterday you can't move between them
right so we that trading application
that we have the Dex it doesn't work at
least not straightforwardly
what's the other downside in terms of
privacy yeah exactly right so now your
anonymity site is partitioned by the
assets if so you know zero cash a will
have its own anonymity said zero cash B
will have its own anonymity set and so
on for C as well right
an idea what you want instead is that
ABC they all share the same anonymity
pool so you don't like learn which asset
is being traded okay see how you could
do that so it will take the construction
on the previous slide and modify the
structure of our coins a little bit all
this information is the same you don't
have to worry about that yeah so instead
of not storing values inside the coin
will also store an asset identifier
right so now each coin has asset ID and
the value and what the proof will ensure
now is that for every asset ID so for
every asset in the transaction the value
of that asset is conserved right so if
you have acid an acid be in the same
transaction like you know c1 old is
asset a c2 all this acid B or something
what you'll ensure is that asset a's
value is concerned in transaction and
acid these values also conserved
independently right it's a little bit of
a technical note on how to actually you
know introduced value and create this
asset ID but we won't go into that you
can look at the paper for videos
so the point is that now this
transaction reveals no information about
the asset identifier or the value right
because again the zero knowledge proof
hides all this information and the rest
of the information is just some serial
numbers and some commitments in the
transaction right so is it clear like
why you don't know any information about
these things
tidy undervalue okay
this is any questions associate home
like if you hide the value use replace
the value now with the ID and value
there
so this you know achieves our goal of
you know multiple private user-defined
assets in the same transaction with the
same anonymity pool but it doesn't
achieve you know our ability to trade
between assets right so your question
about how trade between them is still
isolated there's no like sort of way to
go from acid a to acid B in some sense
okay so the question is how to enable
applications that interact with multiple
assets at the same time like the Dex
application so what we'll do now to get
that is we have the same stuff as before
but now inside the coin what we
additionally store is we have the ID and
the value but also some auxiliary
information which we'll use for
application specific purposes and death
predicates you can think of this as like
a sort of Bitcoin script kind of thing
right and the idea is that when I spend
the old coin not only should the value
of the assets be conserved but also the
predicate or the Bitcoin script of the
old or the spent coins should be
satisfied right you could just think of
this as analogous to private Bitcoin
script in some sense and the idea again
is that if you construct as you long as
proof correctly you can ensure that this
transaction again it reveals no
information about the ID value or the
predicate of the consumed coins right
this is a bit of a tricky stuff I would
quite describe how we achieve this in
the paper yeah but you can do this
okay any questions about this so the
difference on the previous slide here is
basically that instead of just you know
ensuring value conservation now you also
log in some arbitrary computation inside
your coin and the idea is that if you
want to spend the coin then that
predicate or that script has to be
satisfied and the input to that script
is the you know the entire transaction
basically yeah I was just curious about
this no information thing there I
wondered I mean are there cases is this
kind of like information theoretic no
information I just wanted to like what
happens if in like you know certainly
small pools small small pools of people
using an asset or with lots of
transactions or maybe something a little
bit different more complex we need
assets as mr. it yes some information
theoretic guarantees or it does depend
from like applications applications if
in application essentially the guy T
that we provide is I feel part of the
it's a bit complicated I guess but
roughly the idea is that we have a
simple like asset transactions then your
guarantee is the entire new matisse at
write this information theoretic you
guaranteed the zero knowledge proof has
this property called particular
knowledge which means that no
information is revealed about any of
this stuff completely if you have like a
specific application which requires you
to reveal information to another party
then that information is revealed right
but that's artifact of the application
and not in some sense of the system
right you could if you redesign that
application to not reveal information
and then there would be no leakage at
all from here maybe maybe you can see in
a second how it would work when we get
to the Dex example
all right any questions about this part
any other questions
all right so let's see how we can use
this you know these in this notion of
death predicates are no private Bitcoin
script in an actual application right
what I want to emphasize just a second
is that these things these predicates
can be any arbitrary computation just
not I mean I'm talking about Bitcoin
script but Bitcoin script is just an
analogy you can put any arbitrary
computation you want in here something
practice def predicates in some sense
because these coins are dying the paper
will also have both predicates we won't
get into that
okay yes any arbitrary computation can
occur within these scripts so let's see
how you can use these for a concrete
application and we'll take a look at
these private atomic swaps and why
atomic swaps because there's in some
sense the key parameter for constructing
X's right when you're trading with
somebody you don't want to be the case
that you know they get your funds but
you're left with nothing right you only
want the trade to go through if both of
you get what you wanted out of the trade
so what we'll do is let's say I want to
trade my asset for some of somebody
else's asset what I'll do is I'll create
this coin which has that isit ID one and
the requisite value and some of their
information we'll see what's in there
and I'll set the death predicate for
that for this coin to be this exchange
that's predicate so let's take a look at
what it is in there so let's imagine
this coin is a part of a transaction
with you know some other input coin and
a couple of other output coins what the
exchange that predicate will enforce is
that you know it'll take a look at all
the coins and it will say okay look
inside see one old specifically the
other information and find out the ID
and value of the coin that you want in
exchange right so so let's say c1 is a
facet type a ox and I want to trade for
asset B I'll put the idea of acid be in
here and the value that I want in
exchange as V Star okay in the exchange
that predicate will check that the other
input coin so this one actually you know
has that relation it is a ID ID star and
have the correct value and then it will
perform the swap
it'll make sure that the output coins
you know have the correctly swapped
values and IDs and it will make sure
that in their address to the right
people right so the new coin is going to
my address that I specified in here and
the other new coin is going to the other
party in that in the exchange there's
make sense so the idea is that this
exchange this predicate will only be
satisfied if you know the other coin in
the transaction or the other coins
satisfy this set of conditions right
yeah there are multiple possibilities
that we still satisfy the predicate so
there
spread in a in a simple thumping
software someone's willing to sell for
at least yeah you could you could change
this this this value condition to be
like you know within plus or minus ten
percent or something you can set it to
be like whatever you want yeah I mean
it's the hard part is it the predicates
can only look me might loosely constrain
the potential outputs how does the
system end up resolving between if if
there's there's several ways of killing
the old coins that would satisfy their
death predicates that depends in
sometimes how you deployed this exchange
that predicate in a concrete application
we will see in a bit how you would do
this in an actual Dex how you would use
this in a new construction some some
sort of Dex any other questions about
this
all right so so for the decks we have
like one component run and we have a
private atomic swap but we have a couple
of things we didn't talk about first of
all we didn't talk about how to
construct or create orders right how to
discover are the orders in the system
and finally how to you know once you
have agreed on some sort of asset value
pair how do you actually go ahead and
finalize the trade okay so let's take a
look at how do this for one popular sort
of exchange decks architecture right
okay so an index based X you have this
sort of public data structure called the
index which maintains a list of
intentions to trade right and what I
mean by intention is just it contains
the asset pairs not nothing about the
actual value of the asset right so if I
am somebody who wants to trade I can go
ahead and publish I want to trade asset
a for asset B please contact me at this
public key encryption public key or
something where is that people who bring
the liquidity the trade the makers
they're the ones who go and publish this
on the exchange on the index sorry and
the idea then is that once this
intention is published a taker can go
ahead and scan this index and interact
with the makers to fill out the orders
at the C right so if they like in order
I can go ahead and fulfill that order by
interacting with the maker alright and
an example of this is the s4 protocol
yes it's actually deployed in the real
world or something I'm making up okay
let's see in a bit more detail how these
things work right is that okay there's
actually other kinds of exchanges as
well which we talked about in the paper
yeah there's different sort of thing 0x
basis changes you can take a look at the
paper if you want to see how you would
get privacy for those as well
so back to our index based X right so
this is the index which you can see it
has you know I want to somebody publish
I'm going to trade some asset for some
other asset and their encryption public
key right and so like that's it this
maker comes along and publishes says I
want to sell a and by be please contact
me at this encryption public key if you
want to like you know trade with me
the ticker says okay this this works why
I want to you know I have some B and I
want to get a intern and the idea is
that now they can interact via this
public key this encryption public key
agree on the terms of the trade right
and in the end the taker will get some
sort of transaction that they can
publish to the ledger at which point it
will be finalized let's take a look at
like what the privacy leakage of this is
right so this transaction which goes to
the ledger it reveals a cup a few things
right first of all it reveals the
addresses of you know the maker and the
taker right it also reveals the values
and you know which assets actually being
traded right and this yes we learn the
identities and assets and values and
this leads to like a couple of different
kinds of leakage right it first it leads
to this sort of trader anonymity so if
you want to prevent this what you want
you end up with two sorts of properties
the first is trade anonymity which hides
in some sense the transaction graph and
namely the addresses of the maker and
the taker and trade confidentiality
which hides information about the assets
and values used in the in the trade now
these two properties are useful to
formalize because they prevent problems
that we saw earlier in the slides right
okay so animal to preserve the financial
privacy of users by hiding the
transaction graph and trade
confidentiality you know it prevents
front-running because if you don't have
this right - can see what the value what
the asset pair is right and what value
is and they can do that front running
that we talked about earlier with paid
confidentiality they have no idea like
rich asset
is being traded and you know so they
can't front run it make sense like why
these two properties are actually useful
fee okay so let's see how we can achieve
these properties right now and construct
this private index based decks okay so
you have maker as before comes along
publishes their entry into the index the
taker says okay I like this let's
interact and they agree on some price
for the trade right and now this is
where we differ from the original
protocol right so the maker they
construct their coin as before right
with set a value VA and now inside the
auxilary information they'll put I want
to get a coin of acid B and value VB in
exchange right and you'll set up the
that predicate to be the exchange that
predicate that we saw earlier well
they'll Lou is now the maker sends over
this coin along with the secret key
that's needed to spend the coin the
corresponding secret key to this public
key it sends that coin to the taker and
let's say the taker actually has you
know a coin c2 that satisfies the
conditions of the trade the taker can
then go ahead and publish and create a
constructive transaction that satisfies
this exchange that's per decade and yeah
and the point is and they can publish
this transaction to the ledger and
because you know this transaction has
that the privacy properties you talked
about earlier we get trade anonymity
because it hides all information about
the sender and receiver right in this
case Omega and taker and it also hides
information about the assets and value
and values involved right so you get
treatment and chattel so you prevent you
know leakage for the privacy of the
users and you also prevent front-running
like attacks
any questions about this
so we constructed these private
user-defined assets and now we saw how
to use this custom access these death
predicates to get private X's right how
much time do I have ten minutes or so
okay maybe I can cover stable coins as
well
right so we had those you know we've got
our private assets and private Dex's
right but now let's say you want to
construct an asset which has some sort
of different transaction policy right
for example you know if you have as
normal
GRC 20 token that corresponds to this
sort of value conservation property
right but if you have a stable coin then
you might need to implement some
policies which correspond to regulations
right you might want to for example
implement blacklist saying I can't you
know this transaction did not involve
any of these blacklisted addresses or
this transaction is only going to one of
these white listed addresses or maybe
I'm this transaction pays taxes or
something like that right all kinds of
regulations you might want to implement
them and while still having privacy
right against everybody including the
regulatory authority you can achieve
this yeah so if you do this now this is
all the same as before
what will introduce is we'll have the
dead pet Achatz as before what we'll
also introduced is both predicates for
the new clients and the idea is that
along with the value conservation policy
what we require is that the birth
predicates for the new coins is
satisfied right so for every new coin
that's produced in the transaction the
corresponding birth predicate is
satisfied and we know we still have the
death threat Achatz of the old coins
still being satisfied and the idea now
is that for example you could use this
both predicates to ensure that you know
this new coin was not produced in a
transaction which had these blacklisted
addresses the point is so now when I
want to use this new coin in the future
transaction right what as what anybody
who's using that coin will know is that
this corresponding birth predicate was
satisfied right inside the coin and so
they'll know that the coin was created
in good conditions like regulation
regulated conditions does that make
sense yes so this this could be
implementing a blacklist right the birth
medicaid says you know c1 all these are
blacklisted coin see to all the thought
of blacklisted coin right and when I use
see to nil in a future transaction I'll
know that that but that blacklist both
predicate was satisfied when the coin
was created so then I'll know that you
know this coin is regulation friendly it
depends entirely on you so you could set
it up to be you know this massive
computation you could set it up to be
like you know just checking two or three
small conditions anything yeah you can
set it to whatever computation you want
I mean you have to probably you know
fiddle around with how to do that
efficiently in some sense and like
without revealing too much information
but depending on your application you
can set it up to the to do any arbitrary
computation inside this
and point is that the transaction would
still be you know verifiable in time
independent of that computation yeah the
inspiration for this work other than the
fact that once you have deaf Pregnant's
it makes sense to have birth practice it
wasn't actually that you've looked at
other stable stable coins and seen that
they implement black lists or was it
that you had to hypothesize that they
will implement backwards black lists one
day so the applications actually came as
like post factor once you had the system
in place already
so both etiquettes are actually in some
sense Eve okay so as you'll see like
sexy itself does not have a concept of
you know a coin or any value or anything
underneath and so what he actually made
these both Farragut's for is to enforce
even the need you need if you go back to
the previous slide when we had just the
deathbed Achatz what we had was the in
substance the birth predicate was
implicit the birth radical was enforcing
value conservation right so even if you
don't have stable coins or regulations
anywhere your birth predicate in that
world would still be enforcing that
value is conserved yeah that's the
simplest birth predicate you could have
for example for an asset then once you
have that then you can go ahead and like
you know yeah generalize that to
arbitrary computation which we did you
present this work other places
it's sort of like an unspoken thing
right now that stable points especially
those that are running on open networks
like aetherium may or may not be
implementing some sort of whitelist or
blacklist within the test of the
regulators it's generally believed that
they're not but they probably will have
to soon yeah if you don't know more
about that I'd be curious but if this
was just sort of you being you guys
being creative to think about how we use
these that's another that's another
matter that knowing that there's a felt
need for regulators that you are
addressing this is a this was not driven
by regulatory needs as far as I'm aware
point there is if if the stable point
issue where is the money services
business which they all they always are
who are their customers the persons to
whom they issue and redeem in which case
it could just be a typical ERC 20 token
and when it comes to you you destroy it
you create a new one you create a new
one yeah or are your customers every
intermediate wallet that hit in the
chain of transactions before it comes
back to you I see
how can you possibly know Wallis you
can't and so the only way to use these
systems if regulators were to say those
are your customers too would be to have
a whitelist or blacklist
yes of course that issue at the moment
they're comfortable saying your
customers are only those to whom you if
you directly interact with yeah probably
for everyone yes in that case you're
having to sort of propagating blackness
or something yes another is another
question yes yeah you know be entirely
comfortable with novel technology yeah
in the future okay so now once you had
these about Farragut's the idea is that
you know you can use it as I said to
conserve the value but also enforce a
mob three policy P regulation friendly
policy okay and we still have a privacy
guarantee this transaction reveals no
information about the birth predicated
predicate or anything about the coins in
fact beyond that some coin was consumed
in some kind of spent
and once you had this you can you know
take this and generalize there's nothing
really specific about coin values
anywhere you could have some arbitrary
data payload and you know arbitrary and
computation happening here and this is
basically the exact C construction in
some sense you can do any arbitrary
computations with any sort of data
payload again they all have coins you
have records of data yeah I guess your
predicate is not a network specific or
is it its coin specific or it can be
either one I guess it just says it's in
some sense application specific but for
the you you will usually define assets
example it's it's specific to the
example but not specific to the token
the specific to the application but not
to the asset in some sense because if
you go back here right the ID is stored
independently of the predicate there's
no information about but about this
asset ID inside the word predicate all
it says is that you know look at all the
coins what are the ass what are the
ident identifiers inside this
transaction for all those identifiers
make sure the corresponding value is
conserved so this both errotica doesn't
really have any IDs hard-coded inside it
yeah the predicate it seems like
sometimes you want some things to be
public and sometimes private like so you
want in some sense the first predicate
to be public as you want to be able to
prove that value is always conserved and
if you're working with regulators you
want to be able to prove that you're
avoiding a blacklist or something but
then the most generic thing like
somebody was able to supply that to sign
something with a key yeah so probably
there are aspects of that that you need
to keep are the predicate public or
private or if they're private by default
how do you prove that there's a birth
predicate so yeah so you're private and
in this system the spread everything is
private by default including the
predicate so if you look at a coin or a
transaction you don't know which
predicates were involved inside the
transaction all you can do is you know
if you have a regulator asking you you
know what's this coin what is the death
particular that and you don't want to or
both predicates and you don't reveal
that information you could have a
separate zero knowledge proof just to
them showing that if I open this
commitment you know you'll find these
predicates inside there inside there
inside the coin so you can do that's
that's in some sense independent of the
system but it's a thing that you could
do if you need to do transacting parties
who were protected by this privacy have
the capacity to generate your knowledge
boosts to third parties about the
transact yes
yeah so as I said you can like take that
system and there's nothing specific
about assets or coins and you render you
could just talk about arbitrary
computation and you end up it
essentially is XE right yeah over
arbitrary data our computation okay all
right so in sexy so there's a I guess to
summarize is a couple of contributions
first we have to provide a model for you
know computing over these units of data
these records right in this UT EXO sort
of model right and then we show how to
formalize our to realize this records
nano colonel in a privacy-preserving
manner over a decentralized ledger so no
information is revealed about the
individual computations and finally we
implement it and these techniques from
tika snarks as well as circuit design
and recursive composition of snarks and
this code is available online at libs
axelrod any questions
[Applause]
any more questions yeah so I apologize
for kind of an somewhat non-technical
question but so it seems so here it here
at Berkeley there's this comments
Gabrielle's economic about the hidden
wealth nations and people kind of hiding
their wealth I just wonder it almost
seems like if you get a nice privacy
coin and that kind of role isn't use it
might be kind of be easy so of course
you have this nice mechanism there where
you might be able to prove that you've
paid your income tax or something really
tough to implement so I don't know I
guess I don't know the specific question
there I mean one question is is this
just kind of silly to even worry about
and you know the possibility of Canada
if you're a crypto maximalist and you
you just imagine is it silly to imagine
a world in which it becomes super easy
to hide your wealth and your payments to
employees right we already live in that
world and so it's actually much easier
for though for the the super wealthy
they it's actually and may even be not
illegal for them to hide their wealth so
I think in this case it's it might
become more accessible to rush the world
making that the sort of Equalization
it's the future is already here so it's
not evenly distributed well yeah but I
guess I'm not really ambitious for up a
world in which you know no one is paying
taxes especially if there's not any
other
sort of mechanism for example or paying
for roads or you know by personal
preferences to have a social welfare
program for example so who's gonna pay
for that in the world learn no one is
paying taxes I know that this is a
little bit too much but I just thought
that item it's when I see privacy coins
on the one hand I think it's great you
know fancy cryptography and privacy
preserving stuff it's amazing and then
the other hand I think and I wonder if
you know this becomes widespread people
who are you know if I even be in their
best interest they want to pay their
taxes but it's just some funny bad and
sniff may prevent them from doing so so
like I guess classic trade-off right now
that we have these encryption water
crypto Wars as well right where this
trade-off between privacy and you know
law enforcement in being able to access
messages of criminals like we've had
this sort of conversation in another
sphere I think it's coming to this
monetary sphere it's a financial sphere
it's an important question but I think
like that's where this sort of ability
for you to have privacy but also still
proving that you know you were
law-abiding with the laws at that point
in time or whatever is necessary right
so you you just have privacy without I
guess any way to show that you you know
were following the rules that's maybe a
bad thing but that's why you want to
sort of like selective disclosure
property that these sorts of systems you
can to you where like you have private
program ability but still privacy right
and I guess the jacksie is like one step
hopefully towards achieving that sort of
accountability with privacy and I guess
navigating that trade-off it requires a
lot more work then I guess what we've
done yeah but that's not a question that
I guess is a matter for this workshop in
some sense right
law and ethics as long as you have
jurisdiction over employers in your
nation
you can pressure them to make payments
to their employees in certain ways and
then you can just rely the typical audit
auditing mechanisms to guarantee that
they do and additionally you could even
perhaps rely on your knowledge groups -
for the for the employee and the
employer to both be able to prove that
well like what holding has been done or
something like that so I think actually
also I mean not only do you want to have
that that you're also gonna I mean you
know if if if someone is paying someone
who is who is naming I mean how are you
how are you going to enforce it if I
mean how are you going to know if
someone is not paying by the normal
mechanisms since you have a
privacy-preserving mechanism I guess my
question I guess is it's a little bit
harder than right now like there be it
be like if you catch businesses that pay
their employees in cash and you know
these are poised seem to be living the
extravagant lifestyles and the business
seems very successful but the IRS isn't
getting anything from any of these
people what's going on you know the zero
knowledge proof that shows that there's
some sort of tax compliance is not
lining up with what we see in ground
truth reality or you buy a very
expensive house you know maybe maybe
this means that we have to rethink you
know how we do taxation maybe it should
be focused on things that are very
observable like land okay all right very
good ice it's probably enough thank you
it's like it's a fun discussion it's a
budget afternoon so thank you but it's
very interesting that there could be
some level